نذهب الى اما ايمن صبحك الله بالخير من
الرياض طبعا ايمن
هذه الاغنيه مثل ما يقولون حديث الساعه
وحديث مواقع التواصل لكنها لم تطرح يوم
امس طرحت منذ فتره شو السبب في انتشارها
الان
والله
اولنا اصبح عليكم بالنور العاصمه واحد
سعاده الجميله هذه
حبايبي الله يخليكم
طبعا هي قبل من 2020 طرحت والحمد لله
انتشرت في اليمن على حدود الوطن يعني
انتشرت ووصلت لثلاثه مليون في قناه غير
قناتي واحتدفت من جديد
صعدت في قناتي وانتشرت على مستوى اليمن
لكن الفتره اخيره يعني
كانهم اكتشفوها اكثر في الخليج في
مسقط في عمان وبعدين في السعوديه ليه
برايك شو العوامل والله في هاي الاغنيه
اللي خلاها تقطع حدود اليمن وتخرج الى
خارجه العالم العربي
ثاني شيء احس انه الاغنيه صادقه في
المشاعر في الموضوع اللي تناولتها يعني
خاصه احنا كمنين يعني المعاناه اللي
نعانيها من جراء الحروب وغيرها
والفراتنا ان احنا نسافر ونهاجر ونقترب
ونكون ونفارق اهلنا وحبايبنا فهذا عتاب
كان عتاب بين حبيب وحبيب
في في عتاب اخر من الجمهور اليمني يقولون
والله انه المطربين او الفنانين
اليمنيين في الخارج لا يغنون الاغنيه
اليمنيه بمعنى انه انتم تغنون
الصنعانيه مثلا الاغنيه الصنعانيه البيضا
مش الصنعانيه التراثيه
كيف ترد
احنا نغني الكل يعني بس انه علشان تصدر
الفن الصنعاني ولا الفن اليمني تحتاج انك
تختار يعني كلمات صنعانيه او يمنيه بس
انها تكون مفهومه يعني نوعا ما توصل في
الاخير الالفين اذا ما فهمت الكلام اللي
فيه كيف بعيش الشعور
اكيد بنتكلم بلهجتنا نسمع
يا ايمن قالت حبيبي هيك مباشر يلا نشتهي
نشتهي نشته نعيش الشعور وياك نشتري نسمع
يلا ايوه نشتي نشتي حلوه
قالت حبيبي
قلتها يا نور عيني
قالت
فقدتك وهجرك قد عبثين
الوصل
واريد الحق ذا الحين
ما عاد بصبر وبعدك باي يجنني
يمين لادعي
الهي بيني وبين
والله يغني عن العلم
ويكفيني
قلت اسمعيني
حبيبي شمالي
سيديناه لكن ظروفك الزمان للبعد تجبرني
يمين
لادعي الهي بيني وبين
لكن
صروف الزمان للبعد تجبرني
قالت حبيبي
قالت قالت حبيبي
قالت قالت حبيبي نور
عينك يا ايمن دقيقه
حبيبتي زوجتي وصديقتي
ونصيبه حبيبتي عسى الله يهنيكم في شيء
جديد ايمن انتهى وقتنا يا رب في شيء جديد
اكيد
مجهزين الحاجات الجديده باذن الله انها
تنال اعجابكم
وترتقي قريبا ان شاء الله شكرا جزيلا
من الرياض الفنان اليمني شكرا جزيلا
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات